on veut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
revoir les amis bons choix ai-je bien
mis mon turban patron nounours tu es
superbe c'est vrai alors je descends
rejoindre mes deux petits amis car ce
soir je danse
musique patron s'il vous plaît
nos noms de la musique
addou
[Musique]
alors vous êtes prêts pour la danse
avec a plus voyons du cola nous dansons
comme aux indes
ce soir
c'est très facile
regardez
il fut
tant mieux car vous savez les hindous
sont des gens charmants mais ils ont de
curieuse habitude ils font danser les
serpents il ya même des gens qui ne font
que ça le charmeur de serpent
pour que l'on
ne me parle pas de ces affreuses bien
que les actes je ne veux plus les voir
dans son
[Musique]
comment
oui ban
jusqu'où il y à un serpent je les ai
entendus
c'est frais c'est tellement beau la
danse addmd
[Musique]
maman papa emilia patrons ont secouru
plus de danse hindoue cette musique
attire sûrement les serpents je me sauve
je me sauve il est l'heure de dormir
à demain à gagner news corp âgées à
demain peut-être s'il n'y a pas de
surprendre
bravo nicolas mas que c'était drôle il
avait peur pour mon
moniteur c'est beau rêve nicolas
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
alors mon vaillant gros nounours tu ne
trouves pas que nicolas siffler très
bien nicolas se tenir collant au le
petit coquin moi qui croyais que
c'étaient les serpents patron mon pauvre
grunner je ne suis pas gros il ne m'a
trappe rond plus le petit garnement
allons ne te fâche pas bonne idée
enfants ados
oh
ouais
en vo
[Musique]